CNBC has this
report barbenheimer isn't the only
phenomenon at the July box office over
the last four weeks Angel Studio's sound
of Freedom an indie film that has drawn
the support of former president Donald
Trump another service has captured
nearly 150 million dollars in domestic
ticket sales
the figure may seem small against
Hollywood Blockbuster performances from
Warner Brothers Barbie universals Super
Mario Bros Each of which have grossed
several hundred million dollars but it's
a solid theatrical run for a film that
only costs 14 million dollars to make a
lot more than solid
150 million dollars from a 15 million
dollar budget
is I mean extraordinary
um it's especially impressive
considering Paramount's Tom Cruise
vehicle Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one has tallied less than
140 million dollars since its July 12th
release
and DC Comics tentpole uh the flash
barely topped 100 million dollars
domestically so
I saw this I I first saw this headline I
actually thought that
I didn't quite believe it at first
that this film that um uh sound of
Freedom has outgrowsed
Mission Impossible when I first saw the
headline I thought okay well you must
mean like profit-wise it has it's it's
gained more it's it's profited more the
profit is greater than um than uh uh
than Mission Impossible and that I would
certainly believe
you know what they're saying is just no
when you stack up how much they've made
period
overall gross of the films sound of
Freedom has made more the mission
impossible
and of course when you factor in profit
the differences are even more Stark
because Mission Impossible has not
turned a profit and probably never will
at this point I don't know what mission
impossible's budget was but it was more
than 150 million dollars that we could
be sure of
now
talk about people having uh hate in
their hearts
this just shows you how much Hollywood
hates conservatives and people of faith
that that you see these kinds of movies
a movie like sound of freedom
huge
incredible success
and and you can have this kind of
success
on a almost non-existent budget
15 million dollars is nothing compared
to these films when they're the budget
200 million 300 million dollars
fifteen million dollars it's like it's
pocket change
it's what you pull out of your pocket
well that's even make a movie with that
so you can make a movie on that kind of
budget
reap enormous profits from it
the audience is interested
and yet uh Hollywood still will not make
these films
I mean sound of freedom is made by Angel
Studios it's not a Hollywood studio
and every time there's another success
with a with a so-called faith-based film
and you start to think well you know
next thing you know Hollywood's gonna
start churning these movies out
over the next 10 years we're going to
see like 20 Bible movies
and it just doesn't happen
because they hate us they hate us so
much that they don't even want our money
we are days away from the Durbin Accords
the greatest threat to the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years on
August 22nd the brics nations are
expected to announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan is to
plant the U.S and the dollar as the
Cornerstone of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now
unfortunately when currencies fail gold
is a safe haven how much more time does
a dollar have ask yourself that well you
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers find out why by texting
wolves to 989-898 and get your free info
kit on gold if a central bank digital
currency becomes a reality it'll be nice
to have some gold to depend on again
text Walsh to
989898 you know you can dangle bags of
cash in front of their faces and they
won't take it
these money grubbing bastards who care
you would think careful for nothing but
money they they will not they don't want
our money
because it would be very easy for
Hollywood to attract
um
you know the audience that goes to watch
sound of freedom
be very easy for Hollywood to get that
audience back into the theater
like like once a month
by just putting out films that actually
appeal to that audience
and they could start by going go to the
Bible
the other thing about the Bible is the
best-selling book of all time
and there are many stories in in the
Bible that are that that
I mean aside from the from the
incredible the truth and the spiritual
significance as people of faith
they're also just great stories
as well
that have uh of course more than stood
the test of time
it would make great films and you could
go into the Bible and say there's
there's a hundred amazing films in there
that from Hollywood's perspective could
make them billions of dollars you know
the Bible to Hollywood could be worth
billions of dollars
and people would go watch these movies
not that I would necessarily not that I
would trust Hollywood to make uh Bible
films and every once in a while when
they attempted it often doesn't go well
but
you would think from their perspective
that this is what they would do just
from a cynical profit motivated
perspective and they they just won't do
it because they don't want our money
um they don't want to make something
they can't they feel like they can't be
proud of it they can't they don't want
to make something that uh
that someone like you or someone like me
would actually enjoy
and they will forego that so my
prediction is that
even though this should be for uh for
Hollywood maybe like a literal come to
Jesus moment for them where they stop
and say like wow we're putting all this
money into these franchise films it's
supposed to be Blockbusters Indiana
Jones Mission Impossible I mean these
are
these are franchises that in the past
have made billions of dollars for us and
and it's getting beat by sound of
Freedom with a with a pocket change
budget
and you would think they would stop and
say well we gotta we got to make some
changes okay we need to
so that we don't go bankrupt
but I don't think it's going to make a
difference
they're going to continue on exactly as
they have been
because they don't want our money
which is fine we don't have to give it
to them I'm fine with that too thanks
for checking out this video if you'd
like to listen to my full podcast on the
go you can check out the Matt Walsh show
on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts